or donc une injonction a été faite à
l'asm de rétablir l'eau dans les
communes de sainte luce il vient piloter
et rivières salue également une
astreinte de 50 euros par jour et par
l'usagé pendant le délai de deux mois
une provision de 500 euros par usager
de leur préjudice et une participation
aux frais de procédure dans cet ogre en
soulagement pour les usagers des
communes de sainte luce souvient pilotes
et rivière salée pour qu'enfin l'eau
soirée tapis danse est connu pour que
chaque foyer composé de personnes âgées
nourrissons soignants puisse enfin avoir
accès à l'eau potable
c'est une grande victoire que ce soit
pour les habitants de la cacem par
rapport au dc et pour les usagers du sud
pour la ixième vous pensez que ça va les
obliger en tout cas essayer de trouver
une solution pour apporter de l'eau va
espérons que oui j'espère on espère on
espère bien parce qu'il faut que que la
situation bouge on ne peut pas rester
dans cette situation